hey guys i'm ryan right em sell em I'm
valley she's Sally yeah it's it's hard
sometime
your own name and hey mighty is done
Jerry can you get the tea please dad
Jerry hurry up Jerry Jerry hurry up
hurry up mother [ __ ] Yi's taking too
long isn't thanks Jerry yeah just be
careful only does something right so
this is going to be our second DVD
reaction it's going to be too anchorman
2 the legend continues super-sized
edition rated R it just came out what
the thing is annoying the theaters for
one week so might as well just make it a
DVD review you know what I mean the cool
thing is Sally did not see the
theatrical version that was released I
did I liked it so I got to see both
sides of movie and she only got to see
one side so I mr. sitting here your take
on it Sally ok ok me first yeah okay I
am actually glad that I saw this one
first just because there were a lot more
and one more what a lot more dude and
how would you know that everyone said
like it was kind of just like cookie
cutter jokes or whatever but this one I
like seeing more and so I mean it was a
bit long like there were times I was
like dude where is this going it's about
really confused as to what was in that
the Africa version of what wasn't
because some of it was just so out there
my favorite part of the volunteer movie
was just Steve Carell and Kristen Wiig
doing their thing like it was so bizarre
I can't even but what it was great i
think i prefer the theatrical version
but there's a lot of things that are
better about this different version of
it even though it's rated R it's not
life full of a bunch of swear words and
nudity it's not it's like they just cut
out a couple of things that wouldn't
have been rated R what I really enjoyed
about it was AI thought the editing was
a lot better i remember the theatrical
version is a little choppy i felt like
they were having a hard time getting him
prob down yeah now i am smooth oh yeah
you can see why because they just kept
going and going good it's like how do
you cut that yeah transition what I also
really liked was I thought they made
every single character look better in
this one they gave them more scenes
allowed them to go on because I remember
watching the first time I saw it I
remember thinking like Paul Rudd's not
really that interesting he they don't
make him great in this one but I thought
he was more funny and in this version I
thought he had a much more like stronger
character I think then than what I
thought he was gonna have
business but now hearing your side I
guess yes both sides the darks even
thought champ was better steve carell
you know I remember watching the
theatrical version going like he's just
kind of loud and obnoxious and that's a
lot different than brick but his timing
in this version and this the way he did
everything I thought was so much funnier
and it was more like the brick we
remembered so yeah it was there's a lot
of things I really enjoyed about of
course Ron Burgundy he's the [ __ ] he's
funny as [ __ ] there's a lot more black
jokes oh my god no was I mean the people
next to me were like they could not
believe what was going on on to ya like
even I couldn't like it got to a point
where the whole theatre was like dead
silent like wondering like is it okay to
laugh like that's how racist these yeah
it gets really racist it got so bad
these girls which is like oh my god like
I came up Hey oh my guy was laughing and
after watching the second time even
though I know it's an alternate take I
really strongly do prefer the first one
it has more of its own style to it this
is kind of feels like how I had a McCain
welfare I'll do collide it's kind of has
this weird it's not like super fast pace
its kind of taking its time a little bit
you could feel the improv that takes
going a little longer as opposed to the
first one which is a lot more snappy but
yeah I still I still really liked it a
lot and uh you know it would I thought
it was was actually interesting because
I'm the type of person that you know if
the movie drags on too long i'm like
okay like come on pick it up like let's
go I mean there were times I was like
wow this is long but I was never not
entertained you know I mean like
sometimes it gets to a point where you
just like this is not entertaining any
more because I'm just bored but it just
kept my inner like it kept me going the
whole time just like I wonder what
they're gonna say next so in that sense
the fact that they could drag it out
that long and it still be great it's
almost two and a half hours yeah but the
fact that they even did that and it's
just talking mainly it just shows how
much talent these guys have yeah I think
they work better together in this one
that they did in the last one but what I
will say that I did miss that was really
in the first one was the first like 30
minutes of this film seems like it's
gonna be about Ron Burgundy and the news
team and then after a while you kind of
forget about the news team they're kind
of just to the side for a lot of the
movie and that's what kind of sucked
because it's like everyone was excited
to see them all come back together but
then it just became a strictly Ron
Burgundy story you kind of neglect in
use team was
is this one had musical numbers that
were really funny it's rare when I see
like a comedy musical and I'm like damn
these musical numbers are Steve Karass
is one part if you haven't seen the
movies are I'm going to give it away but
he sings about spider-man of imported
the most random moment it's so [ __ ]
funny it's just sitting there an after
the whole thing I just whispered to Ryan
and I was like who wrote the script
hitched it and said this is gonna be a
great idea because it i just i don't i
don't understand let's take them a long
time to get it made writing to them a
long time to get like produced a lot of
people were rejecting the idea for many
I can see that I mean they pulled it off
perfectly but I can see how they were
like there's no way they can pull this
off to be funny you know it was just it
was so out there but it was good laughs
yeah the whole time Sally was like what
the [ __ ] huh she does that thing when
she just looks over at you he's like oh
like what is this is so random two and a
half hours of sitting next to that what
about the endings that stood out to you
besides the fact that this matters the
toilet the amount of comedians that just
showed up at the end oh you mean the
collision okay yeah that's not the
ending i play we're talking about a
break on married and stuff look [ __ ]
okay the climax the climax of the movie
was it's this huge fight scene but I'm
just gonna say there are a ton of
celebrities that show up and it blows
your how did they get all these people
to be in it I don't know well from what
I heard a lot of people were asking to
be in it really yeah Marion can't let
her like she got offered a partner she's
like I'll do whatever even if it's one
line and she only had like I think one
line yeah but she's not as big as the
people I was done oh yeah I think I
forgot who else has to be in it Oh even
kanye has to be in it is not the car
near Drake yeah in a career is still
trying to you know it's in I can
understand I'm Kanye with like I need
something to make me cool again but
isn't he is it you doing all right now
is it had a kid what
Kim Kardashian the yeah they're [ __ ]
felicitated like baby celebrity and on
the planet and he still hasn't recovered
from the whole VMAs thing no people
actually look at him as a joke now
people still buy his music I mean he's
not hurting from it anymore I'm just
saying like he's kind of a joke though
yeah to the was kind of an ass that's
why interweb Kanye if you're watching
this I did not just say that Oh mom I
did though Obama said you're an ass so
long be loud maybe that homeboy an ass
at Obama talk that's my impression of
Barack Obama's the most racist
impression ever uh yeah I am agree with
that i think is very racist say your
Obama brush it was trying she sound like
someone who's very uncomfortable-looking
talk with someone okay so yeah um
anchorman 2 I really like this other
version i think you should watch both
versions and decide which one is better
yeah i'm gonna watch the first one after
watching or i mean i'm gonna watch the
second movie that isn't the uncut one
just to see like how they how it
actually was supposed to go yeah exactly
but yeah this is exciting time for us
honestly i would buy it Wow hmm that's
our rating
Oh